if you want to hear a story about the
height of kleptocracy or maybe better
said the depths of cronyism currently in
charge of our country this is the story
for you Donald Trump has confirmed that
he wants to host next year's g7 summit
at his own Doral Golf Club in Miami
Florida this would be completely
unconstitutional and this is not my
opinion it's the opinion of legal and
political experts because there's this
thing called the emoluments clause asked
why he wants to do this this is
hilarious Donald Trump said well it's
convenient because it's close to Miami
Airport check out a visibly sweaty
sniffing and Confused Trump making the
case for this after arguing with a
reporter about what counts as a question
and then making himself a martyr for
willing to be President of the United
States take a look here we go question
for you on next year's g7 summit but can
I just clarify something you said you
mentioned earlier today one question let
me do the clarification and then I get
to the question you talked about one
calls with China and a breaking news
alert them to understand what
specifically we heard from China and on
next year's g7 you alluded today drop
several hints about Miami about Doral
and hosting next year's g7 at your
property what reassurances if any can
you give the American people that you
are not looking to profit off the
presidency well I'll tell you what I've
spent and I think I will in a
combination of loss and opportunity
probably it'll cost me anywhere from
three to five billion dollars to be
president and the only thing I care
about is this country couldn't care less
otherwise I wouldn't have done it people
have asked me what do you think it costs
and between opportunity not doing thing
I used to get a lot of money to make
speeches now I give speeches all the
time you know what I get Zippo and
that's good and I did a lot of great
jobs and great deals that I don't do
anymore and I don't want to do them
because the deals are making a great
deals for the country and that's to me
much more important
Doral happens to be within Miami it's a
city it's a wonderful place it's a very
very successful area of Florida
it's very importantly only five minutes
from the airport the airport's right
next to her it's a big international
airport one of the biggest in the world
everybody that's coming all of these
people with all of their big entourage
is come it's set up so / and by the way
my people looked at 12 sites all good
but some were two hours from an airport
some were four hours from a that was so
far away some didn't allow this or they
didn't allow that with Doral we have a
series of magnificent buildings we call
them bungalows they each hold from 50 to
70 very luxurious rooms Trump also very
interested in racking up minibar revenue
during the g7 that's why he wants Russia
back in Putin's entourage will show up
to Doral in the new g8 and they will
just Oh Trump tons of money because of
all the vodka consumption this is just
so stupid and so illegal completely
unconstitutional this would violate the
emoluments clause against a government
official self enriching by virtue of
being in office if Donald Trump was not
president there would be no discussion
of holding a g7 at a Trump Golf Club
this is a way in which Donald Trump is
self enriching by virtue of being
president of the United States or
potentially self enriching Trump
constantly sends signals to foreign
officials about where should they spend
their money
Trump has already racked up endless
violations of the emoluments clause and
this would be another one and the thing
with Trump is maybe it's a good thing
compared to corruption behind closed
doors although there's plenty of that
with Trump with Trump a lot of the
corruption is out in the open I'm
wondering is it possible that doing the
corruption and the cronyism out in the
open
helps Trump get away with it in some way
if the g7 was at some secret location
and later it turned out that it was
Doral or Mar
Lago maybe that leads to more outrage
and consequences than Donald Trump just
saying straight up the at my golf club
for all of the cow towing to and praying
to the altar of the Constitution though
I would love to just hear Republicans
say this can't happen
this can't happen but even though they
fetishize the Constitution it's actually
a lot like the Bible for them we've
talked about how a lot of Republicans
are all about the Bible but not really
they're all about the parts that are
convenient for them some things
something about abortion something
something about gay marriage because man
lying with another man or whatever
otherwise who cares when the Bible is
not convenient for you they similarly
claim to be all about the Constitution
but it's only certain parts right the
Second Amendment and their complete
misinterpretation of it that they are
definitely in favor of for sure
the First Amendment for people they
agree with absolutely the emoluments
clause that sounds like something that
should only apply the Democratic
presidents and I'll tell you this if
Crump wants to do the g7 next year at
Doral or mar-a-lago or whatever he will
probably get away with it the way it
will go down is we'll hear it's about to
happen for month after month after month
outrage
panels debates then it will happen even
the legal experts say oh yeah this is
clearly illegal it'll be a week of
corporate media panels about is this
impeachable is it not impeachable blah
blah blah
legal experts again will continue to be
united and say yeah this is illegal then
Trump will threaten to nuke a tropical
storm or something and everybody will
move on and forget about it and he'll
get away with it like he's gotten away
with everything else fiasco after Fiasco
cronyism swamped filling worldwide
embarrassments the media outrage cycle
chases it for their own benefit and then
we move on to something else when Trump
says let's bomb a hurricane or send
people back to [ __ ] countries or
whatever and there's a very good chance
I hate to tell you this there's a good
chance this is not going to end in
January of 2021 with the inauguration of
a Democratic president there is
a good chance and we need to recognize
it and we need to prepare mentally for
it because I don't want to see the
crying on November whatever 2020 if and
when this happens there's a good chance
this is going to go on until January of
2025 when Donald Trump will be 78 years
old and will be completing eight years
as president of the United States
be prepared buckle up because it may
well be happening that is sort of the
bulk wrapping up our g7 coverage
yesterday and today it has been an
extraordinary embarrassment half the
country thinks that it was some major
alpha-male victory of some kind for
Donald Trump but anybody who understands
sort of how the world works in basic
geopolitics and diplomacy understands
that this was truly the height of
embarrassment for our country make sure
you follow the David Pakman show on
instagram at david pakman show we will
have a poll and other content related to
the g7 and while you're there follow me
at David Pakman I have posted a video to
my Instagram of a Portuguese dog now I
don't mean a Portuguese water dog I'm
not talking about the breed I'm talking
about a dog from Portugal named poo Liga
which means flea in Spanish or
presumably in Portuguese as well I'm
guessing who watches the David Pakman
show okay there is a Portuguese dog that
watches the David Pakman show daily and
I have a video of that dog on my
Instagram at David Pakman follow me
there we'll take a quick break much much
more after this I actually have some
good news for you today farmers are
furious with Donald Trump now the reason
that they're furious is not good which
is they're getting crushed absolutely
destroyed by Donald Trump's tariffs and
Trump's pointless fruitless endless
trade war but the fact that the farmers
are now correctly blaming Trump for what
Trump did is a good thing Trump's lies
often work and frequently they go
unpunished we have in front of us step
one in Donald Trump actually
during the consequences or suffering
some consequences from his lies which is
that farmers are identifying them as
lies this is step one step one is
acceptance Donald Trump's tariffs have
led to massive drops in a number of
agricultural exports soy beans pork
wheat a number of other farm exports now
the administration has tried to sort of
make up for this by subsidizing farmers
which sounds a lot like the socialism
that Donald Trump claims to be against
but okay anyway it's not been enough
farm bankruptcies are climbing farmers
are buying less and less farm equipment
so the manufacturers of the farm
equipment are starting to suffer the
problems are trickling up so to speak
and Donald Trump subsidies just aren't
cutting it Donald Trump has now
straight-up started lying and saying
farmers are doing great again it's not
true but much like the China phone call
that never happened Trump realizing that
things aren't going well with a trade
war and saying don't worry
China's desperate to figure this out
they've called me to start trade talks
of course they haven't there was no such
phone call Donald Trump is simply saying
Oh things are going great for farmers
now and fortunately the farmers are
actually pushing back and the farm
groups are saying no things are not
going well quote from Brian Salman who
is the president of the Minnesota Corn
Growers Association there are dozens and
dozens of these groups Brian thälmann
saying we're not starting to do great
again things are going downhill and
downhill quickly will they vote as a
result of that we don't know but at
least they've correctly identified that
Donald Trump is lying the National
Farmers Union says Donald Trump's
tariffs are making things quote worse
not better will they vote on the basis
of that understanding we don't know more
and more individual farmers like Bob
colon are saying I'm doing terribly
since Donald Trump came into office and
it's getting worse and worse so that's
all good this is just what we call step
one then it gets to where the rubber
meets the road
will these farmer
vote for a Democrat in 2020 will they
stay home we heard from the same farmer
Bob Cooley into CNN quote if he doesn't
lose he being Trump if Trump doesn't
lose 100% of it from the farm belt then
people are kind of crazy because this is
not going well for farmers at all our
farmers going to vote for someone else
our lifelong Republican farmers in the
Midwest going to vote for a Democrat in
2020 I hope the answer is yes but I
don't know and this is something I've
been talking about for a long time just
because a lifelong Republican is
displeased with what Donald Trump is
doing or with some aspect of what Donald
Trump is doing doesn't mean they're
going to vote for a Democrat now that's
okay and I'll explain that in a moment
we actually had a phone call a couple
phone calls from Trumpets who say I
don't like that Trump hasn't built the
wall
and I asked them it was Doug from Jamaal
in fact I remember I said to Doug okay
if Trump doesn't build the wall by 2020
are you not voting for him and he said
well no I mean okay I I probably still
would and more than likely the reason he
won't build the wall if he doesn't is
because of Democrats standing in the way
or whatever so it's really important to
understand that any dissatisfaction you
hear from these lifelong reliable
Republican voters with Donald Trump it
doesn't mean they're going to vote for
someone else but here's the upside even
if they just stay home on Election Day
it's not a bad thing assuming that the
left can get our base out to vote in
November of 2020 because let's be very
very honest about this if they haven't
decided not to vote for Trump in 2020 by
now they're either voting for Trump or
maybe staying home with most of them the
best we can hope for is that they stay
home and that's okay because they're not
going to vote for a Democrat but the
reason why this is all okay and we
shouldn't worry too too much about these
farmers not voting for a Democrat is
that national elections are not won by
convincing people on the other side to
vote for your person in large numbers
right there cannot really be an election
where 130 million people vote or
whatever than
is flipped by arguing with people and
changing their minds when half the
country doesn't vote it's about getting
out the vote and then will accept
anything that depresses vote on the
right or splits the opposition vote so I
talked earlier this week Trump has a
primary challenger a Republican former
Republican congressman joe walsh is
running in the primary maybe he will
eventually run as an independent will
some angry farmers in the Midwest
maybe opt to vote for joe walsh or stay
home as a result of that that would be
fine we would gladly accept that maybe a
few percent of the National Republican
electorate that isn't pleased will Trump
with Trump will choose to stay home
they're not going to vote for a Democrat
but they won't vote at all that still
helps us as long as we get our base out
this is the path to a win and these
farmers even if they don't vote can be a
part of turning what was in 2016 an
election that ultimately was decided by
75,000 or so votes in three states
just a few farmers staying home in
combination with us getting our base out
can actually make a difference maybe
some of them will actually go and vote
for the Democratic nominee I don't know
but we don't need them to do that is the
point I told you before our vacation
last week that our friend JD Shelton is
once again challenging incumbent
disgusting Republican Steve King in
Iowa's fourth District in 2020 we met JD
Scholten down at Netroots nation in
August of 2018 he ran against JD against
Steve King in 2018 and lost by only
three points very sad because it would
have been amazing to knock off one of
the most vile and despicable members of
Congress King is in trouble and JD
Shelton is running King has said crazy
things about abortion King has
reminisced about when white supremacy
and white nationalism weren't offensive
saying to the New York Times during an
interview white nationalist white
supremacist Western civilization how did
that language become offensive but King
is in trouble Republicans have abandoned
him and he has almost no money this is
so funny
hasn't received one donation from a PAC
associated with an existing member of
Congress this is a common way that these
guys fund each other corporate packs
aren't donating to Steve King special
interest groups aren't donating to Steve
King in the first six months of this
year King received to two donations from
third party political entities one was
from Lamar Smith a Lamar Smith
associated PAC former Republican
congressman and $2,000 from Todd akin
Todd akin is the guy who said that the
body shuts down a legitimate rape and
thus the woman can't get pregnant
that guy is saying I want to donate
$2,000 to Steve King Republican Party
groups are also not donating so this guy
can be defeated think back to 2018
JD sholden lost by only three points in
2016 I'm sorry in 2018 back when Steve
King was still able to raise money this
guy Steve King is someone who came to
power as a tool of big business quite
frankly he came to power because the
bankers gave him money he came to power
because big builders and companies like
AT&T and big food gave him money big
insurance gave Steve King money they're
not giving him money this year and
that's really really bad for Steve King
so as usual there's the good and the bad
the good news is that without money he
can more easily lose 2jt Schulten the
bad or at least the troubling part is
how did it take until 2020 to realize
for Republicans that they need to
abandon this guy and the answer is they
don't really care they're playing now
like they're oh they're so disgusted
with the things that Steve King has said
no this is the same Steve King that's
been around all along and while this
wasn't a problem for them King was
another vote in the House and that's why
they wanted it it's not that he was
someone that they disagreed with or
agreed with or whatever they were
indifferent they just want someone to
check a box and say yes I'll vote
Republican now he's become a PR problem
so they're abandoning him let's not
attribute to morality and ethics what we
can attribute merely to Republicans
seeing politics as sport wins and losses
checking boxes and that's it but he
needs to go hopefully he will in 2020
check out JD Shelton's campaign JD's a
former professional baseball player
super nice guy hung out with him in in
2018 in New Orleans as I mentioned he
came so close in 2018 with the loss of
steve king's funding and the abandonment
that steve king is suffering from his
republican party colleagues this could
be an amazing time to get a Democrat in
the Iowa fourth congressional district
check it out check out JD Scholten and
hopefully we'll be talking to him on the
program we'll take a quick break after
this we have extraordinarily great
submissions for the David Pakman show
EDM dubstep voicemail remix theme song
if you have no idea what I'm talking
about
then I think you're gonna like it even
more I have some really strange video
for you today it has been just
embarrassing anecdote after embarrassing
anecdote from the g7 and France for
Donald Trump over the last few days and
I really want to do this thoroughly and
that's why the entire show so far has
been g7 related stuff Donald Trump's
only notable contribution to the g7 as I
mentioned before has been ruining a
dinner with world leaders by insisting
that Russia be added back into the g7 to
once again make it the g8 which it used
to be until 2014 he's contributed no
ideas to better the planet he skipped
the climate change meeting he's made no
sense in almost everything he said but
the sort of height or the bottom of this
embarrassing Fiasco was Donald Trump's
explanation of why he wants to add
Russia to the g7 now I'm gonna play the
clip for you it's under 90 seconds in
duration but in the clip Trump attacks
Obama on foreign soil a bad look for
presidents says things that are just
straight-up wrong which is not probably
a shock to you and seems to suggest that
Russia should be back in the g7 because
Putin took Crimea from Ukraine while
Obama was president I know that that
doesn't seem to make any
logical sense because it doesn't make
any logical sense but it seems to be
what Donald Trump is saying let's take a
look they were really it was a President
Obama not blaming him but a lot of bad
things happened with President Putin and
President Obama one of the things that
happened was as you know what happened
in with a very big area a very very big
and important area in the Middle East
where the red line was drawn and then
President Obama decided that he was not
going to do anything about it you can't
draw red lines in the sand you just
can't do it and the other was in Ukraine
having to do with a certain section of
Ukraine that you know very well where it
was sort of taken away from President
Obama not taken away from President
Trump taken away from President Obama
President Obama was not happy that this
happened because it was embarrassing to
him right it was very embarrassing to
him and he wanted Russia to be out of
the what was called the g8 and that was
his determination he was outsmarted by
Putin he was that smart and President
Putin outsmarted President Obama women
and I can understand how President Obama
would feel he wasn't happy and they're
not in for that reason now I'm only
thinking about the world and I'm
thinking about this country in terms of
the g7 whether it's g7 g8
I think it would be better to have
Russia inside the tent than outside the
tent why doesn't Trump name anything an
important area with a red line
Syria a certain section of Ukraine that
you know well Crimea Putin took Crimea
not from Trump but from Obama
therefore Trump wants Putin back in the
g7 so I'm trying to read between the
lines here I think maybe what Donald
Trump is saying is that Obama screwed up
with Russia Russia took Crimea from
Ukraine under Obama's watch this
embarrassed Obama or it angered Obama
so Obama retaliated by unfairly kicking
Russia out of the then g8 and that
that's a silly reason to have Russia out
so Trump wants them back in basically
what Trump
seems to be trying to articulate in
completely failing way is Obama wanted
Russia out and I do the opposite of
Obama
so bring Russia back in now there there
are so many logical contortions or
pretzels here one is not everything that
happens while someone is president is
their fault like is it Donald Trump's
fault or responsibility that Argentina's
economy is crashing even more right now
it's not it's happening wild Trump is
president but not because Donald Trump
is president so that's problem number
one
problem number two is that Trump sort of
seems to be saying since Putin
outsmarted Obama and took Crimea from
Ukraine under Obama's watch he doesn't
deserve any punishment for it and
getting kicked out of the g8 was Obama's
Way of punishing him for it or something
like that which is bizarre and then also
remember that Russia was suspended from
the g8 after annexing Crimea on the vote
of all of the other g8 members period
there are many criticisms that we can
make of the g8 or the g7 which are valid
number one they're not doing nearly
enough to fight climate change that's a
very significant and pressing it
criticism of the g7 they are
perpetuating the status quo of damaging
neoliberal globalization rather than
limiting it that is a fair and accurate
critique of the g7 they are lacking
buy-in from some major industrialized
countries more like what you see in the
g20 but this is not only childish
nonsense that Donald Trump is adding as
I mean I'm calling it a critique
although to call it bad stretches
credulity significantly it also is not
even really adding to these serious
critiques that there are of the g7 and
of the ways in which these seven or the
broader g20 nations control so many
aspects of the everyday lives of so many
people on this planet and it's just it's
a waste of time it's a diplomatic
embarrassment and it's a geopolitical
embarrassment quite frankly for
Americans who have to if they
and what's going on I know the Trump is
defend everything that the guy does but
if you understand what's going on you
see the u.s. embarrassed
day after day press conference after
press conference by Donald Trump and the
sort of height of this is what I want to
talk about next which is that Donald
Trump wants the next g7 at one of his
golf clubs Trump has been touting a 51
percent approval rating from some very
specific right leaning pollsters but the
reality is that Donald Trump's approval
rating has dropped to its lowest in 2019
which is 36% this is looking at one poll
that has been done over time it's The
Associated Press poll it's been tracking
Trump's approval for his entire
presidency and right now Trump's
approval is 36% his disapproval
is 62% so let's contextualize this let's
explain why it matters and then let's
talk about how it relates to 2020 first
of all the context Trump's approval has
been in the range of 32 to 42 in The
Associated Press poll since day one so
it didn't go lower than 32% approval
it's never been higher than 42 percent
approval that's a small range of only 10
points that one one thing that relates
to is the hyper partisanship and
polarization in the United States
politically we've talked about that
before
right now Trump is at 36 that's pretty
close to the middle of that 32 to 42
range a little bit on the lower end and
that ties the lowest approval of 2019 so
is this some kind of breaking news that
changes everything Trump approval at 36
well not in the sense that Trump is in
the middle of the approval range that
he's had all presidency secondly some
partisan context if you look at
Democrats 95% disapprove of Trump
Republicans approve 79% and independents
approve 65% that's an important number
the 79 percent that Republicans approve
this is important because Trump's been
touting and Republicans have been
leaning on Trump has 95 percent approval
among Republicans I don't know what poll
that is this is a good poll that we're
looking at and it says hold on a second
7
9% of Republicans approve of Trump this
matters in the context of a primary
challenger which now Donald Trump has in
former Congressman Joe Walsh and I'll be
talking about that later in the show 95%
approval from your party and 79 percent
approval from your party are two very
different things and in a primary the
goal of which would be not to defeat
Donald Trump in the primary it's not
going to happen but to do some damage to
Trump that is going to be significantly
influenced by the difference between
Republicans approving of Trump 79
percent versus 95 percent so that's
important also important there are three
areas where Republicans actually
disapprove of Trump's handling more than
they disapprove of him overall so again
remember 79 percent of Republicans
approve of Trump however only 77 percent
think he's handling health care
correctly only 75 percent say he's
handling foreign policy correctly and
only 70 percent believe he's handling
gun policy correctly this is important
and it's interesting but Republicans are
not going to vote for a Democrat because
they disagree with Trump on these issues
this is important to understand for
Democrats gun policy isn't a voting
issue by and large for Republicans gun
policy can be a voting issue if you are
on the wrong side of more guns in more
places
but the reality is if you're a
Republican and you don't love Trump's
take on guns you're not gonna go and
vote for a Democrat over that that's the
reality
Healthcare a lot of these Republicans
25% of them they might recognize Trump
is completely bungling healthcare but
they're not going to go and vote for a
so-called socialist health care plan
from a Democrat they're still gonna vote
Trump they just don't like what he's
doing on health care
similarly foreign policy foreign policy
is just not a voting issue in the way
that domestic economic issues are so
that gets us to what do we do with this
data whether it's 36 percent approval or
32 percent approval or even in the
twenties Donald Trump can still win
re-election I've run the numbers before
with you half the country doesn't vote
you could have a twenty
six percent approval and turnout one
percent more voters in some key states
than the other party and win because
half the country doesn't vote so
following Donald Trump's approval is
relevant and it helps us to understand
how people especially Republicans are
reacting to Trump it does not tell us
anything about what's going to happen in
2020
all you need to know is that Donald
Trump could have a 36 percent approval
rating and easily win and by the way the
fact that he has a 36 percent approval
rating tells us that there are tens of
millions of people who are so
disconnected from reality or
ideologically blinded that they don't
care what happens in the real world they
are voting for Trump in 2020 period okay
Trump has tens of millions of votes in
2020 already it's August of 2019 the
elections in November of 2020 Trump has
tens of millions of votes once you know
that you realize this becomes
get-out-the-vote because we're not going
to be able to convince these people in
any large numbers I know I'm a broken
record at this point I've been talking
about this for so long this is going to
be about get out the vote that needs to
be our priority in our context heading
into 2020 tell me if you think there is
some other way in which Trump's approval
is relevant beyond reminding us
he's got tens of millions of votes in
the bank already and we've got to get
the vote out follow us on instagram at
instagram.com slash david pakman show
and oh I have a new story on my
Instagram page David Pakman got back
from vacation big developments with my
tomato plants huge developments make
sure you're following me on instagram at
instagram.com
slash david pakman I have a clip for you
today of right-wing pundit ben shapiro
which may be his dumbest ever and i know
that that is saying a lot
Shapiro is known for employing a
technique of speaking quickly and
confidently which to some people gives
the idea that he knows what he's talking
about but he often says really silly
things
quick reminder here he is talking with
me about gun control when I interviewed
him a few years ago and
didn't really take that much to get them
visibly confused it's a very simple
argument from my point of view and that
is the people if they have the right to
bear arms in order to prevent tyranny
then that that goes for arms to prevents
it that goes to the the the ultimate
limit of that is the arms necessary to
prevent the basically you can own any
arm that is necessary to necessary not
rather than to prevent tyranny anyway
make sure you check out that entire
interview but let's talk about Ben's
latest comment the latest comment is
America has already apologized for
slavery the Civil War was a national
apology for slavery 1619 as folks are
calling it is a massive retelling of the
American story with african-americans
appropriately at its center it is the
kind of retelling that continues putting
the calls for reparations in the proper
context and makes the absence of a
national apology all the more galling so
in other words it backs Jonathan Kaye
parts agenda there was a national
apology for slavery it was called the
Civil War where 700,000 Americans died
so that that seems to have been kind of
important in American history this may
be the dumbest thing he said there is no
interpretation in which this makes sense
there was a national apology for slavery
called the Civil War where 700,000
Americans died the Civil War was not an
apology for slavery the Civil War was
only necessary because half the country
was willing to die to keep slavery who
apologized someone who does the fighting
to keep slavery is not apologizing for
slavery someone who dies fighting for
the Union trying to abolish slavery is
not apologizing for slavery they're not
even defending it how could they
possibly be apologizing for it this
makes no sense under any circumstances
and I'm having trouble understanding
whether ben shapiro doesn't understand
history or doesn't understand slavery or
doesn't understand the definition of
apology or maybe some combination of the
three
if the south was apologizing for slavery
why did they put up endless monuments to
civil war generals who were fighting
for slavery that's not usually how
apologies work and so what you have to
understand is that Ben Shapiro serves a
role in right-wing media and he plays a
character in right-wing media the
character he plays is the facts and
logic guy but really it's just his
delivery that may give people that
impression not the content of what he
says the role he plays is the
intellectual right-winger who provides
rock-solid arguments for right-wingers
to feel good about their incorrect and
immoral positions and that's how you end
up believing that single-payer is some
form of slavery against doctors and yet
actual slavery is bad but the US has
already apologized for it by having a
civil war now there is maybe a silver
lining here some of you probably are
anticipating this he seems to be
admitting that the Civil War was about
slavery that's sort of an accomplishment
because very often right-wingers love to
say civil war wasn't about slavery it
was about states rights states rights of
course to own slaves but he's actually
saying that it seems to have been about
slavery and I think that that is
actually an accomplishment in some way
shape or form maybe some kind of
progress I do get scared when people
call into this show and they say David
I'm on the left and I love what you do
but I like to hear
strong reasoned arguments from the right
so I listen to ben shapiro that's scary
stuff and we should all be very scared
when we hear people say that there are
things the president can do that we just
think are the wrong policy and there are
things presidents sometimes do that make
us question the entire democratic
process and i'm punching my mic already
because i'm so fired up about this that
got the president elected in the first
place today is one of those donald trump
has suggested multiple times that we
should bomb hurricanes bomb hurricanes
to stop them it sounds like a satirical
news headline it sounds like a joke but
it's the suggestion not of a random 73
year old guy that you just saw urinating
underneath the subway platform these are
the words of a 73 year old guy who
happens to be president of the united
dates and the White House is not denying
it here's a paraphrased quote this is
the stuff of Horrors I got it I got it
why don't we nuke them Trump said they'd
start forming off the coast of Africa
as they're moving across the Atlantic we
drop a bomb inside the eye of the
hurricane and disrupt it
why can't we do that per Axios who is
reporting on this asked how the briefer
reacted to trump suggestion the source
says that the briefer said the Trump sir
we'll look into that there placating
Trump this is how it works behind the
scenes Trump says what about bombing or
nuking hurricanes and they say sir we're
gonna take a look into that Trump
reiterated the suggestion that the
government can intervene with bombs
against hurricanes before they make
landfall multiple times and listen Trump
seems to think he knows a lot about
nukes right remember this beauty having
nuclear my uncle was a great professor
and scientist and engineer dr. John
Trump at MIT good good genes very good
genes okay very smart the Wharton School
of Finance very good very smart you know
if you're a conservative Republican if I
were a liberal if like okay if I ran as
a liberal Democrat they would say I'm
one of the smartest people at where in
the world screw but when you're a
conservative Republican they try do they
do a number that's why I always sort of
went to Wharton was a good student went
there went there did this built the fort
yet I have to give my like credentials
all the time because we're a little
disadvantage but you look at the nuclear
deal the thing that really bothers me it
would have been so easy and it's not as
important as these lives are nuclear is
so powerful
my uncle explained that to me many many
years ago the power and that was 35
years ago he would explain the power of
what's going to happen and he was right
who would have thought yeah so that was
all one sentence by the way the briefer
in another case when Donald Trump
suggests that bombing hurricanes was
reportedly quote knocked back on his
heels and that it became so quiet in the
room that you could hear a gnat
Bart in the meeting according to a
source that spoke to Axios Trump has
reportedly brought this idea up multiple
times with the Department of Homeland
Security with national security
officials with a senior administration
official asked about this the White
House is not denying it they said we
don't comment on private discussions
that the president may or may not have
had with his national security team
that's an admission that this was
suggested by Trump okay in the world of
politics if you were presented with
something completely ridiculous that of
course didn't happen like hey we heard
Donald Trump suggested going out and
personally murdering people in the
streets like Trump wants to go out and
shoot some people is that true is that's
something Trump said you would
immediately have multiple officials
saying absolutely ridiculous the
reporting is false never said it
absolutely ridiculous they said
something here that's almost as crazy
why don't we bomb hurricanes and the
White House is saying we don't comment
on what the president did or didn't say
and there's another administration
official who's actually defending the
idea saying that quote Donald Trump's
goal is simply to keep catastrophic
hurricanes from hitting the mainland
which is a good goal to have this is a
defense of the idea of bombing
hurricanes that Donald Trump's has
suggested multiple times so let's go
through it Trump's not the only person
to think of this idea okay
back during the Eisenhower era it was
considered we knew a lot less at the
time is it possible that we could use
these new bombs that we made to disrupt
hurricanes seventy years ago however
long ago was scientists agree it just
won't work period the only disagreement
that exists with this story is did Trump
suggest bombing or did Trump suggest
nuking the Hurricanes so bombs
non-nuclear weapons versus nuclear
weapons there are reports of both that's
the only disagreement that really exists
here now it's also kind of interesting
that in the background of this once
again it's always near non-white people
that Trump is thinking of dropping the
bombs right like I get this is probably
just a coincidence
but Trump is thinking
let's bomb the Hurricanes where they
form near Africa maybe coincidental but
just sort of notable nonetheless given
how this administration has been run if
Trump were a family member or a friend
if you cared about him if Trump was a
personal contact you would have staged
an intervention by now and you would
have gotten the person some help how did
we elect someone this stupid or unhinged
and then the answer is well because 60
million people thought this was a good
idea and that basically tells you
everything you need to know about the
American electorate this is a crisis the
crisis is Trump but the crisis is also
that there are tens of millions of
people who are going to enthusiastically
vote to re-elect the guy in November of
2020 ultimately this is going to be a
get out the vote election and that
relates to what I want to talk about
next
so yesterday Donald Trump unleashed a
multi tweet tirade against Fox News and
we can now say that Donald Trump has
fully turned on Fox News exactly as I
predicted months ago
first I'll tell you what Donald Trump
said yesterday then we'll go back to how
this has been building for a while now
Donald Trump is furious that Fox News
even had Democrats on their channel
saying that there are it's time to look
for something else and also saying a lot
of other bizarre and completely just
unintelligible things so let's take a
look Trump tweeting in a three tweet
tweet storm yesterday quote just watch
Fox News heavily promoting Democrats
through their DNC communications
director spew T spewing out whatever she
wanted with zero push back by anchor
Sandra Smith terrible considering that
Fox couldn't even land a debate the Dems
give them nothing CNN and MSNBC are all
in for the open border socialists or
Beyond Fox hires give Hillary the
questions Donna Brazile Quan Williams
and low ratings Shep Smith hopeless and
clueless they should all go the way that
they should all they should go all the
way left and I will still find a way to
that's what I do win too bad I don't
want to win for myself I only want to
win for the people the new Fox News is
letting millions of great people down we
have to start looking for a news outlet
Fox isn't working for us anymore so this
has been building for a while I've been
talking about this but before I even get
to that it's so it it seems patronizing
the language that Donald Trump is using
when he tries to explain to people on
Twitter that he wants to win for them
and that it's all for them for most
people who have sort of like a
understanding of the real world it's the
most patronizing and childish way or
demeaning way for a 73 year old
president to be speaking to the country
but clearly this is language that
actually does resonate with people
people actually see Trump speak to them
in this way via Twitter or speeches or
wherever else and it seems sincere to
them and it seems genuine and that that
that's just a problem I think that is a
bigger picture issue than Trump even but
let's put that aside for a second this
anti Fox stuff has slowly been building
for the last several months I've been
telling you about it there's no fixed
relationship that's set in stone between
Donald Trump and Fox News you might
remember if we think back to the
beginning of the 2016 primary Fox News
was not behind Donald Trump at the
beginning of the 2016 Republican primary
they didn't take him seriously they
didn't think he could win they didn't
support him Trump had some pretty public
fights including with megyn kelly and
others on Fox News and Fox News was
quite opposed to Donald Trump and very
publicly so and eventually I guess Trump
I'm going for memory Trump's sort of
reconvened and made up with megyn kelly
and eventually Fox News sort of came
around to Donald Trump and has been
quite frankly a pretty effective
mouthpiece for Trump for a long time
Trump co-opting numerous Fox News hosts
Jeanine Pirro Tucker Carlson Sean
Hannity developing personal
relationships with these people
Maria Bartiromo on Fox Business another
example and it's been a pretty good
propaganda mouthpiece for Donald Trump
for a while now but over the last
year-and-a-half
sort of every once in a while
a little more over the last year a
little more over the last six months
every once in a while Shep Smith or
Chris Wallace or someone would say
something uncontroversially true about
Donald Trump that contradicted what
Donald Trump had said or the weekend
anchors might do coverage that Donald
Trump doesn't like or whatever and
slowly but surely Donald Trump has been
more and more angry with Fox News
because even Fox can't keep up the line
100% of the time that's the truth they
can't placate Trump all the time when
all Donald Trump does is lie and every
once in a while they have to tell the
truth now I've also said that Trump if
he turns on Fox News may well start
promoting the even crazier Network Oh a
n1 American news which if you watch it
looks almost like a porn parody of what
a right-wing news channel would look
like but Oh a n is not joking Oh a n is
for real this is my clip talking about
this from a few months ago Fox News is
not necessarily going to stick with
Trump they're about profit and
right-wing propaganda in a general sense
Trump might be the vehicle for that
propaganda but he also might not and
just to prepare you if Trump and Fox
have a falling out you need to know that
Donald Trump's network of choice is
going to become this absolutely wacked
out thing called Oh a n the one America
News Network or one American news check
it out online but not with kids in the
room and not close to meal times because
it is truly it'll it'll turn your
stomach
but Oh a n is where Trump will go if
ultimately he abandons Fox News as the
propaganda vehicle of choice and then of
course about three weeks ago Donald
Trump tweeting watching fake news CNN is
better than watching shepard smith the
lowest rated show on fox news actually
whenever possible I turn to Oh a and n
one America news network
so listen yes this was written on the
wall months ago and it does seem to be
happening I've said before we are not
going to win in 2020 because of a
primary challenge against Trump we are
not going to win in 2020 because Donald
Trump gets impeached we are not going to
win in 2020 because Donald Trump turns
on Fox News but
every single one of those things could
hurt Trump slightly an impeachment
inquiry against Donald Trump would
replace coverage of Trump's campaign
with coverage of the impeachment inquiry
that might damage Trump half a point in
a number of key states a primary
challenge against Donald Trump which he
now has from former Republican
Congressman Joe Walsh and I guess still
sort of from former Massachusetts
governor William weld although you don't
really hear much about that they're not
gonna win the primary but if they get a
few points of support from the 20% of
Republicans that don't approve of Trump
and then maybe Joe Walsh decides to run
as an independent in 2020 maybe it'll
siphon off another half point or one
point or two points from Trump in some
key state it's not going to be the sole
difference maker that we can count on
and in the same way if Donald Trump and
Fox News part if Fox remains
conservative but not a pro Trump 110
percent of the time propaganda
mouthpiece and instead Donald Trump
starts going to promote Oh a n or
whatever which will have far lower
ratings maybe that also does just a
sliver of damage to Trump in some states
where it might might make a difference
in the end if we combine all of these
things with just getting our base out
half the country doesn't vote let's just
find people who agree with us and
explain to them the importance of voting
all of that together may well lead to
Donald Trump's removal that's my sense
right now and so you know we I did a
stream earlier this week with a former
Wall Street financier who now is like an
independent trader and the entire thing
struck a lot of people in the audience
like this is like very Wall Street
center-right stuff and I've been arguing
for a long time we can simultaneously
identify the problems with the system
but also use the tools that the system
provides in the best way we can to our
advantage and this is why I think that
even though there are so many structural
inequalities and problems with our
financial system I still think it's
important to be informed about savings
accounts CDs mutual funds basic
retirement planning and budgeting in all
of this stuff because these are tools
that we can use to our advantage in the
exact same way we need to think of the
tools that we have that we can use to
our advantage in 2020
I hate the status quo of campaign
finance but it is the status quo right
now and campaign advertising is
something that can be effective so
Democrats should do it the nicknames and
branding that Donald Trump is so
successfully used it's childish and it's
stupid but it's not violence and it is
effective if you read the work of George
Lake off so Democrats should take
advantage and try to brand candidates
including Donald Trump in a similar
fashion to how Donald Trump has branded
Democrats and in the exact same way
Trump's primary challengers all of these
different things we're talking about
Trump splitting with Fox News these can
all be little tools that we can try to
foment a little bit just to try to gain
that advantage because in the end it all
can contribute to ultimately removing
Donald Trump make sure that you follow
me on instagram at David Pakman we will
take a quick break and be right back
after this